[Applaudissements]
comme ça on acoustic ou plâtre en
acoustique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mobile et en talent si ce sont les
paroles alors et là c'est un mec qui se
casse pas le cul exactement c'est bien
dans le rythme forcément ça ça
fonctionne et on ne travaillait grève
est très bon c'est vrai ce que j'ai vu
le film
dave est très bon j'étais très très
surpris dave qui est un epic muscat man
show la rotonde non mais c'est pas c'est
pas facile de passer de chanteur et
comédien il joue très très bien
c'est ce qu'il ya une super ambiance
mais j'aimerais savoir est-ce que tu
l'as vu le film est-ce que je les vicois
pardon mon cul
[Applaudissements]
à
alors
oh
dans l'intervalle interne n'était pas le
doigt dedans vous n'en sortirez jamais
je vous dis c'est le doigt dans ce jeu
je ne savais pas interview patrick team
suite mais pour patrick tromper c'est un
peu le niveau ça peut être pas mal alors
je vous donne le début des phrases si
vous me dites voilà où dit la suite
j'aime pas le téléthon on y voit
beaucoup trop d'eux alors de chanteurs
de variété oui mais ça ça serait la
mauvaise foi ça serait la mauvaise
langue voiliers de dire que deux
chanteurs de variété française
non on n'en voit pas assez enfin je sais
pas je dirais quand même ils sont
handicapés ils n'ont pas besoin de se
taper de obispo
j'essaie d'être méchant